so if you're in a binge-watching mood
over the weekend or you simply want to
watch every single MCU movie before
Avengers 4 comes out then I've got good
news for you
Marvel has released the official
timeline for the MCU giving us the
proper way and order to rewatch our
favorite films in preparation for
Avengers 4 this timeline actually clears
some things up as it addresses the
continuity error with spider-man
homecoming if you're not sure what that
is stay with me and you'll find out also
if you're new to my channel I'm doing a
giveaway giving away a copy of Infinity
Ward the art of the movie art book along
with infinity war Deadpool 2 or ant-man
and the wasp on blu-ray as well as some
special edition posters if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so the official
timeline for the MCU comes to us from
the book marvel studios the first 10
years which came out this week the
official starting point of the MCU of
course starts with Captain America the
First Avenger the events in this movie
take place from 1943 to 1945 and which
Steve Rogers became a human popsicle for
a few decades then we go to the first
Iron Man movie in which the events of
that movie took place in 2010 this is
different than when the movie was
actually released in 2008 but Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige commented
on this here's what he had to say it
wasn't meant to flummox
anybody exactly and I'm not sure I'd do
it again the same way but it does all
connect to where we placed it other than
very particular instances where there's
a newspaper or verbal reference to years
we never dated the films and I think
there's a presumption well if the movie
came out in November 2017 and must take
place in November 2017 which is not the
case in other words if a movie comes out
in a particular year that does not mean
the events of that movie take place in
the same year following Iron Man we got
Iron Man 2 The Incredible Hulk and Thor
all of which the events of the movies
took place in 2011 then of course in
2012 we got the Avengers and right after
we got Iron Man 3 then in 2013 we got
Thor the dark world and then in 2014 it
was a huge year for events happening
inside of the MCU we got Captain America
the Winter Soldier guardians of the
galaxy vol 1 and guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 it appears that the events of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 happened
immediately after the first guardians of
the galaxy movie then in 2015 we got the
second Avengers movie Avengers age of
Ultron and ant-man then in 2016 we
watched all of the Avengers fight each
other in Captain America Civil War and
then finally some clarification
according to the official MCU timeline
spider-man
homecoming took place in 2016 in
spider-man homecoming it says that it
took place eight years after the events
of New York which is wrong it took place
four years after the events of New York
this made fans furious and also very
confused but Marvel Studios did us a
favor and cleared it up for us
officially stating that the events of
spider-man homecoming took place in 2016
and remember what Kevin Feige said it
wasn't meant to flux anybody exactly and
I'm not sure I'd do it again the same
way but it does all connect to where we
placed it so the official timeline of
the MCU says 2016 so therefore the
events of spider-man homecoming took
place in 2016 the next movie in the
timeline is Doctor Strange in which the
events of the movie took place in both
2016 and 2017 and then the MCU had it's
arguably biggest year ever with the
events of Black Panther Thor Ragnarok
and Avengers infinity war all happening
in 2017 so there you have it the
official timeline of the MCU remember
just because a movie came out in a
particular year does not mean that the
events of that movie happened that year
and at last Marvel Studios has finally
fixed that huge continuity error it was
spider-man Home Coming the events
officially did not take place eight
years after the events of New York which
was 2012 but the events took place four
years after so there you have it the
official timeline of the MCU go binge
them all right now and then come back
here in a few days or however long it
takes you to do it and tell me how
excited you are for Avengers 4 and don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]